depuis quelques années les inscriptions
en production maraîchère sur petites
surfaces dans différents établissements
d'enseignement atteint des sommets et
ses nouveaux agriculteurs tirent
d'ailleurs vers le haut le nombre de
fermes une première depuis des décennies
au québec mais vivre de l'agriculture
même quand on est animé d'une grande
passion ça vient aussi avec des défis
[Musique]
et
moi ya fait un battage arrivée à la
ferme à 6 heures le matin qui fait les
oiseaux le laboureur c'est fait
les firmes de plus petite taille comme
les maraîchers bio est en cif je dirais
pas que c'est une mode c'est même une
tendance de fond nos élèves pour la
moyenne sont plus vieux souvent première
année ce qui me disent le plus fiction
c'est pour des raisons d'autosuffisance
ce qui les rattrape souvent si la
réalité de ce qui s'ils veulent démarrer
une entreprise agricole bleus c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour eux cédés
gagne de passionnés qui font là leur tri
mais c'est fou
on a toujours été sur la ferme animaux
pareils nous emmener dans le champ
on venait faire le train impliqué à
saint-christophe-d'arthabaska dans le
centre du québec c'est ici sur la terre
agricole de son père que jo annie
desrochers produit ces légumes elle
cultive une quarantaine de variétés sur
une parcelle de l'ancienne ferme
laitière je me sens quand les animaux
s'étaient pas pour moi là il va chez le
7 jours sur 7 à l'année ça s'arrête
jamais
c'est en 2016 qu'elle lança son père
l'idée d'un projet de ferme maraîchère
sur la terre familiale m'avait dit ewald
maraîchage un peu mais c'est de crève la
faim
fait que j'avais jamais abandonné l'idée
ce laboratoire à ciel ouvert se trouve
ici à hemmingford en montérégie
un peu plus tard elle est intriguée par
un reportage de la semaine verte qui
traite de culture sur petites surfaces
sans grosse machinerie agricole son idée
se précise quand j'ai vu ce géo bon ok
ça ça serait peut-être une possibilité
de force sur un bout de terrain de la
ferme c'est un chant de pointe et vierge
son père accepte et adapte une partie de
ses installations pour y intégrer sa
production maraîchère la pépinière si
c'était une étape alors on est isolé on
a fait un mort on a mis en recouvrement
on installe et de l'électricité on a
amené de l'eau pour arroser moi je suis
tout seul comme propriétaire de
l'entreprise jeu très chanson pour mon
père pour seul parce que sinon il y en a
fallu que j'aille chercher des
professionnels
[Musique]
à
jo annie desrochers n'est pas la seule à
s'intéresser à la production maraîchère
à cinq kilomètres de là se trouve la
ferme école du cégep de victoriaville
les jeunes ils veulent retourner à la
terre à avoir des entreprises agricoles
puis ça sort ça sur les bancs d'école
dans le peu partout au québec
normalement ça a fait diminuer le nombre
de fermes au québec mais une hausse l'an
ces nouvelles fermes diffère du modèle
traditionnel
pierre antoine gilbert peut observer
cette transformation cette nouvelle
agriculture c'est pas les mêmes super c
agricole l'on s'entend c'est pas des
fermes laitières on est surtout dans le
secteur la production de légumes comme
une belle journée
l'agronome enseigne depuis dix ans à ses
futurs producteurs à l'institut
nationale d'agriculture biologique
l'agriculture bio intense et c'est à
dire sur petites surfaces ont fait du
maraîchage très très peu mécanisée celle
là est vraiment à la tendance il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de fermes de nos
finissants qui ont été lancés sont
vraiment tourner vers ce modèle
au cours des dix dernières années
seulement le nombre d'admissions aux
différents profils autre que la
production animale a explosé ici au
cégep de victoriaville leur nombre est
passé d'une quinzaine en 2011 à près de
130 en 2021 dirais qu'on a peut-être 80
% d'élèves qui sont un secteur pour 20%
qui vont suivre nos cours de production
animale il constate que dans bien des
cas les élèves sont plus âgés il s'agit
pour eux d'une deuxième carrière un
métier qu'il choisisse et dont il faut
tout apprendre
la majorité d'entre eux mêmes c'est pas
déjà qu'ils viennent d'une entreprise
familiale donc c'est pas ce qu'on
appelle la relève va parapher on va être
plus dans des contextes de relève non
apparentés ou des néoruraux donc des
gens qui viennent s'installer à la
campagne mais qui sont pas tenus et ont
grandi à la ville la classe que vous
pouviez venez demain
keven richard enseigne depuis dix ans à
l'institut de technologie
agroalimentaire du québec à
saint-hyacinthe il constate une
transformation de fond l'émergence d'une
agriculture à deux visages aux antipodes
l'un de l'autre
les grosses entreprises qu'on dirait
qu'une plus grande taille plus grandes
exploitations ont tendance à grossir
davantage et aussi les plus petits qu on
voit émerger de plus en plus qui est
plutôt à taïwan chaîne humaine pour une
relève qui n'est pas issu du milieu
agricole au niveau économique c'est ce
qu'elle peut faire le plus festif pascal
upon seulement deux bâtiments à acheter
à l'époque quotas de production à
acheter parce qu'il n'est pas sous
gestion de l'offre il y en aura de plus
en plus dans le portrait au québec
même si en proportion ce type
d'exploitation demeure marginale les
fermes qui génère moins de 50000 $ en
revenus bruts sont celles qui ont le
plus augmenté en nombre depuis dix ans
au pays
c'est en agriculture qui parfois fait à
temps plein ou des fois qu'ils payent
tally mi temps avec un travail extérieur
pour avoir une meilleure viabilité mais
honnêtement si les trois premières
années qui sont très dur pour eux de se
mettre dans la réalité
si pour la plupart ce mode de production
et viable il reste que plusieurs s'y
cassent les dents c'est le cas de
nathalie forage
seror que tu entends parler
de du peu d'argent de surfeurs du stress
que tu vas en vo après avoir complété
son cours en gestion d'entreprise
agricole
la résidente de sainte julie a fait
l'acquisition en 2010 est d'une terre
pour produire des légumes biologiques à
carignan au sud de montréal
après deux ans de travail éreintant elle
s'est mise à déchanter
[Musique]
finish est mort tu vois plus mes enfants
ils voient pas monde change pas de
vacances à la fin de l'été 2020 la
productrice abandonne et vend son
entreprise on a une canicule pendant un
mois je peux vous rappeler ce qui me
gêne pas pourtant nathalie forage
n'écarte pas l'idée de relancer une
ferme maraîchère plus modestes cette
fois en monoculture par exemple c'est
sûr que ça sera toujours quelque part
mon ami d'un appel du carrelage de pas
là quelque chose comme ça c'est vraiment
un appel du coeur c'est pour ce polonais
cet appel ces futurs producteurs
maraîchers longtemps tendu aussi et
c'est un rêve qu'il compte bien réaliser
c'est sûr ça sera pas facile c'est sûr
que je vais travailler plus que de 40
heures semaine mais si je veux faire
quelque chose que j'aime je pense qu'il
ya vraiment moyen de rentrer dans son
argent puis on en voit maintenant des
exemples de petites firmes qui ont en
fin de semaine de congé
des fois ils ont peut-être une idée un
peu bucolique de la réalité du monde
agricole fait que l'on retourne à la
source c'est-à-dire de démystifier ckoi
de l'autosuffisance c'est quoi avoir un
potager versus
être maraîchers ou maraîchère ces po1
cours de potagers 101 de jean 5
oh
plusieurs entreprises qui en fait la
démonstration de la viabilité maintenant
ce qu'on voit c'est l'essor de mise en
marché un peu alternative
et des gens qui vont se mettre en
coopératif finalement pour essayer de
prendre les carottes 2 1 les pommes de
terre de l'autre puis de faire
finalement être mis en marche et
collecté coopératives ou fiducie
agricole culture en serre vente directe
les concepts de gestion et de mise en
marché se développe en même temps que
ces nouvelles fermes
l'agriculture urbaine va prendre
énormément de place dans les nouvelles
firmes qui vont voir le jour dans les
années à venir et que toutes sortes de
formules qui commencent à voir le jour
qui vont se développer à vitesse grand v
dans les années à venir moi mon avantage
c'est que mon kiosque et à la ferme
s'est ouvert 7 jours sur 7
les offres sont si parfaits ex'im c'est
pas des paniers suis comme un marché
finalement
des micros producteurs donc qui doivent
tirer leur épingle du jeu quitte à louer
une parcelle de terre chez un producteur
déjà bien établis ou même devenir
gestionnaire ou simple employé d'un
exploitant soit ils peuvent s'associer
avec un producteur qui a pas de relève
que l'entreprise est bien monté et le
bien ficelé donc ils vont quand même
c'est pas nous irons très bien en vivent
économiquement sans nécessairement être
propriétaire des biens ou des lieux
agricole mais cette révolution du
paysage agricole entraîne aussi une
concentration d'entreprises et grandes
exploitations continuent de gagner du
terrain en rachetant les autres l'europe
toujours la place pour les grandes
exploitations dur des produits à plus
grande échelle mais il y aurait de plus
en plus de ces petites entreprises là
c'est certain est ce que le chiffre
d'affaires grossir sûrement mais ça sera
pas parce qu'on a grossi l'entreprise ça
va être parce qu'on a réussi à cultiver
mieux finalement la parcelle qu'on a
je le vois vraiment dans une grande
optique de développement durable pour le
québec d'avoir un territoire qui est
occupé avec des supers entreprises
finalement qu'il valorise ce territoire
là tous les niveaux